-Alright, alright, alright
alright, alright.
I know, I know it's Madonna.
Alright, here's how this works
-I'm gonna, I'm gonna --
Here's how it works.
-People are freaking out
right now.
Okay, The Roots, The Roots are
gonna play us a beat
and Madonna and I will tak
turns showing off
our best dance moves.
Madonna -- since you're Madonna.
Why don't you go first.
-Hi.
-You ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Yeah? Cool. Alright.
Dim the lights.
Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One, two, three, four!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Oh my. Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why am I even --
-Thank you.
-Why am I even trying?
-You know what, you've got t
always aim --
-Look at me.
My suit doesn't even light up.
This is embarrassing.
Come on.
-Is that true?
-Yeah.
Is mine going to light up,
or what do I do?
All right, here we go.
I can't see this.
All right. Dim the lights.
And whenever you're ready,
I want to try something.
-Good luck.
-One, two, three, four!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Yes! Don't hurt yourself.
Did you hurt yourself?
-I think I pulled something.
-His grandpa moves.
You like his grandpa moves
-I pulled something, all right
-Yeah.
-Madonna, you are up again
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One, two, three.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
That's not fair.
All right. I got to top.
I got to top. I got to top
Alright, here we go.
Ah, ah ooh, ooh. All right
Wait. What do I do?
okay.
-I'm going to --
-I know -- I think I know.
Okay, ready, okay. Ready.
Here we go. Ready, all right
Roots.
-One, two, three, four.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was not bad.
-I did pull something there.
-Yeah, that was a game changer
-That was a game changer,
really.
All right, this last one here.
Let's do this.
-Maybe, should we maybe
do it together?
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, oh no. Oh, should I do -
-Yeah, let's do it.
-Yeah?
-Let's do it together. Yeah.
-Okay.
-I'll follow your lead.
-I mean, I'm honored.
Let's do this last one together.
Here we go. Okay.
-I hope you stretched out
your hamstring.
[ Light laughter ]
Come over here.
It requires looseness.
-I --
-Get over here.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three, four!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Madonna, everybody!
That's all the time we hav
for "Neon Dance Battle."
Stick around. We're talking to
Madonna after the break.
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪